you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a group
of five puzzles and each of them it's
white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best play for white ok the
solution to puzzle one is to capture a
couple times on the d8 square and at the
end of it you'll note that the black
King is without a flight Square and the
Queen is still on the back rank this is
these are two issues that white can now
take advantage of because after the
capture on a6 the bishop and rook are
converging on c8 and with rook to ca to
follow on the next turn pinning the
Queen to the king the Queen will be won
back in short order and so I've seen
this in many cases from my experience
when you do have the King without a
flight Square and in a very important
piece the Queen in this case being on
that vulnerable back rank ideas like
this present themselves you'll note that
from the initial position ideas of
capturing on f7 might have been tempting
in many cases this does turn out to be a
nice tactical shot but here it's faulty
since after Queen takes bishop and let's
say queen takes rook black is not forced
to recapture on d8 recapturing on da
white would be winning since the Queen
would have to block this would be
winning for white but black again not
forced into capturing on this da square
instead Queen takes f2 is available with
Bishop b7 you get the idea black would
be winning this position moving on to
puzzle 2 once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
play ok the solution to puzzle 2 is
first Bishop c3 anywhere but King to a4
allows the knight to grab on b3 so let's
see what happens
after King to a 4 you will turn out to
be main three King c4 b - the only move
Knight b3
and pick your favorite way to promote 95
that turns out to be main this of course
is not the best way to put up resistance
by black what's better is to play to be
5 or c5 let's say King B 5 now we just
have Knight takes pawn and eventually
white will round up these two a pawns
and we'll have to give checkmate with
the bishop and night alone if you don't
know how to do how to give checkmate
with the bishop and Knight to the right
of this video I've included a link to a
video where I explain how to do just
that you have to have YouTube's
annotations enabled in order to click on
that image to direct you to the video ok
moving on to the third puzzle once again
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best play for white ok the
solution to puzzle 3 is first Knight see
one defending the bishop allowing this
pawn to promote and now we have bishop
check King f2 another check King he won
and not Bishop takes Queen your
calculations you might have seen this
far and thought you could just take the
Queen well you could but the resulting
position is now stalemate no legal moves
for the black King it's important to be
patient at this point not capturing the
Queen right away recognizing that that
would turn out to be stalemate and
instead first insert this check allowing
King takes bishop which would be the
only move and now you capture the Queen
the King does in this final position
have legal moves and once again we have
this Bishop and Knight endgame
one other thing to know is from the
initial position trying to immediately
stop this pawns advance is not good
either because King takes bishop then I
could give a check the King comes to the
f1 and soon enough the bishop will have
to give itself up for the eventual
promotion of a queen on g1 okay moving
on to the fourth
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best play ok the solution
to this one is really a nice shot rook
takes on h6
there's two different ways to capture
let's look at first King takes rook King
takes rook runs into a main three with
Queen g5 Queen h4 and if the knight
blocks that's me and if the King tries
to run away the pond delivers me now the
other cool finish is what do you do
after G takes H and if you'd like to
pause the video from here see if you can
find the Megan - and I'm just gonna go
right into it
the main Toninho g8 that still might
have been a difficult move to see from
this position right here Knight takes
Queen is the only move and now
surprisingly enough these two bishops
deliver checkmate it seems as though
with these two knights and Queens so
close that one of them will be able to
block but it's simply not the case
the King is without any legal moves and
this is checkmate so really cool finish
it's something that I certainly
overlooked I did not solve this puzzle
when I looked at it so moving on to the
last one puzzle five once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best play ok the solution of this
one is first b6
and before I get into go any further
into this variation you'll note that
after something like c5 note how black
can block everything up with the move b6
these three pawns are very strong and
will simply sit and wait for this pond
to make a decision if it captures on b6
the pond recaptures captures on d6 yet
again this pawn on c7 would
capture so that would not prove useful
for white to play c5 so it's B six
captures and now c5 creating a lot of
tension if this pawn captures this pond
will run for example D take C allows D
six and one of these two ponds will
promote there's no stopping them
Bishop here you just run to d8 and I'm
not sure what else to even recommend
capture here you promote like so so you
can't at this point after c5 you can't
capture so B take C B take C and now yet
again you can't capture this pawn
advances same story one of these guys
will eventually promote so what is best
is Bishop a3 and now c 5b takes C D
takes C and now how do you stop the pond
from promoting d5 is the only mode of
giving check buying the bishop time - no
- now drop back to d6 and which would
stop the pond from advancing and from
here this is the key move it's very
difficult we're already 5 moves in this
sixth move is the key move you don't
capture the pun capturing the pawn
allows Bishop here and it is black who's
winning
but the key move of king to f5 you have
to stop the pond from moving to c7
Bishop d6 white still pushes Bishop
takes pawn and this is still me very
cool finish something that I came
nowhere close to solving I didn't even
get as far as seeing this Bishop to a3
idea but very interesting position even
getting to this point right here after
the check creating a post on that d6
Square and not capturing but rather king
- f5 I thought that that was pretty cool
again this one now being
stalemate position so that's all for
this video as always let me know what
you thought in the comments section and
I'll catch you in the next video
take care
you